[Music]
family we met them on The Bachelor how
did they react to you embarking on this
journey any concerns that they have I
think initially they were really
skeptical but watching me this season
and seeing how I presented myself made
them believers and so they've changed a
little bit and so they're more
supportive of me being the bass thread
and going out there and putting myself
out there and possibly bringing home you
know a son-in-law the one we heard a lot
about your dad he's a judge but we
didn't get to meet him are we gonna get
to meet him on the Bachelorette and what
does he think of you doing all this well
he's very supportive of it I'll start
there you know like I said he was
skeptical in the beginning but very
supportive of me on this journey and me
finding love
like I said they want to settle off they
want grandkids as far as him being on
the show I don't know we'll just have to
wait and see why was that why wasn't
your bachelor due to his the job that he
has you know being a federal judge and
dealing with a lot of high-profile cases
it just wasn't in his best interest to
be on the show at that time so I'm
knowing the future we'll see could be an
intimidating guy okay okay
[Music]